a question from a youtuber andrea says
uh
business boutique asks a fellow church
member
doesn't pay her bill for services
rendered
from my small business how should i
handle this
biblically
um
well scripture says if you have a
problem with someone sit down with them
confront them and if that doesn't work
take a witness and sit down with them
and confront them and if that doesn't
work sit down with the pastor
and confront them now that would for me
in your situation revolve
involve if there was a good
sum goodly sum of money and that has not
been paid
like this person owes you ten thousand
dollars and hasn't paid you
now the way you phrase this a fellow
church member doesn't pay her bill for
services rendered from my small business
it sounds like it's an ongoing thing
so the second time they don't pay their
bill to you it's your fault
because you extended services to someone
who's unknown is a known
offender it doesn't matter if they go to
church or not
they don't pay their bill and so you can
say
you know to your friend or whoever this
is or this church member say that you
know
as a fellow christian it's a bit
offensive to me that you don't pay your
bill
but i understand there could be stuff
going on in your life but
since you don't pay your bills what
we're going to do is the only way we're
going to be able to
render services to you is cash in
advance which is what we would do with
anyone who didn't pay their bill
we don't extend credit to people who
don't pay bills and so
um we don't extend credit around here
anyway so you just
if you want something you just have to
pay for it and we give it to you you
know that's all it is
we don't like to send you a book and
hope you pay you pay and then we send
you a book i mean it's how this works
so but um you know the
the thing is it's just so distressing
and
sometimes uh in the christian world we
uh
automatically assume or assign
competence to someone because they're at
the church
this person might just be incompetent
with their money
maybe you could suggest a total money
makeover book or a
get into ramsey plus membership and
might help them learn how to handle
money god's ways
and it might be that they're not uh
lacking in character they may be lacking
in organization and you could help them
with that
but um you know either way just be kind
but don't
the problem andrea is that when you
expect
someone just because they sit inside of
a church
to be perfect uh and and you're always
going to be disappointed
because imperfect people are in church
and that's where they need to be
all the perfect people don't have to go
which is none of you by the way but we
imperfect people we need to be in church
so just don't extend credit to them any
further if you want to confront them
that's fine
but that's how you handle it